welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy with the
vision
to look into the time stone and tell you
the 14 million different things that
will be happening in one division
well maybe not that many more like 10
but they're good ones i promise
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down the best fan theories
centering around the disney plus show
i'm going to be talking about some stuff
that was said in the reviews for the
first episode
so if you're one of those people that
doesn't like spoilers whatsoever then
i don't know why here as it's all that
we do anyway
if you are still here thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
the breakdown
okay so according to the early reviews
one division actually picks up
immediately as the two enter the pocket
dimension that wonder has created
this was shown in the opening of the
trailer and it's meant to disorientate
us and basically throw the audience in
at the deep end so we're intrigued about
what's actually going on
this will obviously keep audiences
guessing from week to week
i know the answer is obvious who helped
to create this pocket dimension
will become a big driving force i think
now i think that this alternate reality
will have been built with help from
agnes who may actually be an entirely
different character altogether
fans of the marvel comics will of course
know agatha harkness
a powerful ancient witch who originates
from times before
even atlantis sank but millennia she's
existed
and has helped witches throughout the
centuries scarlet witch
doesn't really have many stand out
villains from the comics but her and
agatha have clashed at several points
i think the name agnes is a hint towards
fans that she's gonna cause
aggro for their character now from the
trailers it seems like we don't really
have a villain properly in place
and i think that this will fall on agnes
before wonder ends up defeating her and
becoming the big bad herself
ultron did say that she would be the one
who tore the avengers apart
and it has been said for a long time
that the madness and doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness
will indeed be her there are also rumors
that doctor strange will appear in this
series
i think if he's showing up it's obvious
that she's caused some issues
in infinity war he very clearly defines
his role as protecting this reality
douchebag and wonder causing problems
with this will in my opinion transform
her into the villain
she will fight against everyone to keep
this reality in place
so that she can be with the sex toys she
loves it so with vision
not he's not he's not a machine he's a
person
but how exactly is vision even alive
well we did see an end game that long
deceased characters were able to return
through the use of time travel
which created branched realities and
alternate dimensions
now this does open up the opportunity
for wander to have pulled the vision
that we see
from another timeline however i i think
that he will actually be a completely
new version of the character
and this is why he seems confused over
his death
i think that we will follow him trying
to unearth exactly what happened to him
throughout most of the episodes this
will sort of add a robocop aesthetic to
the show
and i predict that it will be revealed
that wonder actually manifested the
entire dimension
along with most of those in it which
we'll get into in just a bit
so vision will be completely created
from her reality bending powers
and this is why the mind stone still
exists though it won't possess the
powers that it had in reality
bishop was always completely overpowered
in the mcu
and thus depowering this slightly means
that he can face challenges in the
future that have real weight to them
now on top of this i think vision
returning opens the door for other
deceased characters
and i think that we will be seeing aaron
taylor johnson's quicksilver throughout
the season
similar division i can also imagine that
he will be unaware of what happened to
him
and he will sort of be a shell of the
person that he used to be if you watch
the disney plus marvel legends shorts
that were released over the weekend
then you'll have noticed that they
brought a lot of attention to both
pietro and wonder
i think this was done on purpose and
it's to hint to people that watched it
exactly what's going to be coming up in
the show we also learned that evan
peters will be in the show
and no i have seen it posted that he
will be mephisto
i actually think that the character will
also just be a version of quicksilver
from an alternate dimension
going forward it seems like the next
faces in the mcu will be highly focused
around bringing across
alternate versions of characters and
this is why we see the back of lady loki
in the trailer for his disney plus show
i think the mcu is gonna go far beyond
that and
several of the characters that we know
and love will get alternate versions to
them
based on the things that have come
before this is why andrew garfield
electro and dr octopus are returning for
spider-man 3
and from what i hear we can actually
expect to see alternate versions of big
characters
which it sounds pretty crazy for now
from
bit of a side tangent yeah yeah but from
what i've heard and the crazy rumors
have been sent
there's actually going to be tom cruise
playing tony stark in an alternate
dimension at one point and
joaquin phoenix will also appear as
doctor strange
all rumors though yeah that's i don't
know if that's true or not now i i think
this will be how the x-men come across
though
and it will allow for actors from the
already established fox franchise to
drop
in that's the thing that evan peter's
role will be quicksilver himself
and that he may even end up playing the
main mcu timeline one
and becoming a permanent fixture after
this this
bringing back figures from the dead also
allows ultron to become a possibility
and though i do think that's probably
unlikely hey
the door's always open now wonder
bringing people back from the dead in
alternate universes will of course cause
a lot of havoc
and outside of this pocket dimension
will be introduced to sword
i know this was shown in the leaked
images yeah and i'm an idiot yeah
just just let me have this one victory
please just this one time
now the agents of shield were very much
about tackling problems on earth whereas
sword tend to go beyond that it will be
interesting to see if characters like
daisy and coulson are brought across to
the mcu
but we do know that they're sending in
monica rambo who we last saw as a kid in
captain marvel
now we did see in the trailer that she
got thrown out of the dimension
and since then the tv spots have
revealed that she's trapped in the
facade of wonders reality
if you know the characters from the
comics then you will be aware that she
actually becomes a superhero known as
photon
and i predict that the show will
introduce her powers and abilities at
some point it's even possible that when
she was hurtled out of the reality
that in breaking the barrier between
dimensions at such speed
that she was given some powers but
that's probably a reach
she did get thrown out of it really fast
though and land without a scratch
so who knows something may have happened
now what this also leaves the door open
too
is that wonder can create people with
incredible abilities
the x-men and mutants in general are
coming to the mcu
and personally i think that they will
set up the latter before bringing them
all together in the school for things
going forward
the legends show put a big emphasis on
this being an age of miracles
and hey we know the x-men are coming
across at some point
so why not start to introduce mutants in
the show
wiccan and speed are of course appearing
as her children so things are slowly
starting to slot into place
and it just makes sense for them to lay
the groundwork here if you've read house
of m then you'll know that it ends with
wonders saying no more mutants
and i think that this will be slightly
reversed in the show with her actually
creating them
and unlocking the mutant x gene and
several people across the planet
that book ramped up to the massive
avengers vs x-men ark that is probably
one of my favorite marvel stories
so they can start to set that up here
for the climax of the next phase
then i think it'll really get fans
invested anyway that's the predictions
and theories
and obviously let me know if you agree
disagree
or have even better ones as a thank you
for interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize straw in which
we're giving away three copies of the
hobbit and lord of the rings 4k box set
to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories if you want something
else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of what exactly is going on
with the three batmen
that are in the dc right now we go over
robert pattinson's role
michael keaton and ben affleck so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know
more it's on screen now but if not thank
you for sitting through this video
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace